- On this episode, I don't
let Felicity get away with it.
(laughter)
Cool.
(applause)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 99
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Before we start, follow me DRock.
Just follow me DRock
because we just gotta
take care of some business.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Felicity I'm using you as an example.
What many may not know
is Felicity was sitting
a couple of seats over.
She didn't want to be in the shot so
let this be a lesson to
everybody whose gonna run away.
If you run away the camera will find you.
Felicity the camera will find you.
Alright, we can go back.
So that was fun.
That was a good tone setter.
That's right Steve.
Keep your shit together, Steve.
If you run from the camera,
the camera will find you.
Alright, I'm ready.
That was a good start.
Feelin', feelin' a solid
beginning to the show.
Alright.
- [Voiceover] Jared asks,
"Where's blogging at these days?
"I feel like it's not as popular as it was
"a number of years ago.
- Jared, good question about blogging.
Blogging, you know, what's
happened with blogging,
is blogging is massively important
it's just not the thing
that people talk about.
Not only that, blogging became so big
it become the establishment.
I mean if you have a website and you're
putting out content on
it, you're blogging.
And what has also happened
is social networking
has in theory become the micro
version of that blogging.
And so now everybody in theory,
as a matter of fact
Twitter was flat out known
as a microblogging platform for many.
Zak?
Can you just show Zak's face?
(laughter)
I feel like you were
hacking the show, right.
Like you put them on knowing
that I would respond to that
and then get on camera.
- [Zak] I just want fame.
Got it, okay, okay, cool.
That was amazing.
Twitter was known as a
microblogging platform.
So I think Facebook and Instagram
and you know Medium,
there's platforms that
people are now using.
Because what people
started understanding was
they want exposure.
If you're blogging you
wanna talk to the world.
What people aren't as good
at is actually getting
people then to come and see that.
They're relying on SEO back in the day
and things of that nature.
What people realized is that people
are living in Instagram and in Pinterest
and in Facebook and in Twitter.
And so they're now going to
the people and blogging there.
You know, telling a story in your home
and nobody's there is quite lonely
and not that interesting.
That was what would
happen to a lot of people
in the blogging sphere.
Whereas going to town
hall and getting on there
and grabbing a mic and talking,
maybe some people will listen.
But maybe that person was better.
Everybody's talking, everyone's listening.
So it's just the evolution.
The thesis of people wanting communicate
on the Internet hasn't changed,
the formation, the way it's looked at,
the terminology that we
use, the new, you know,
recarnation of it is just what
you're living in right now.
- [Voiceover] Soundspace
asks, "My business is
"completely digital,
"focused on exclusive
and shareable content,
"how important are real life meetings?"
- Soundspace, to me,
real life meetings matter
because human beings make
all decisions, right.
Like, so far, thank God, the
robots haven't taken over.
But it's coming.
But, you know, hopefully,
I don't think I'll see it.
But it's coming.
And so, while that's still the case,
real life meetings matter because there's
just so much context that can be done
in human interaction that
doesn't happen over digital.
You can't map everything.
I feel plenty of emotions over Twitter
and things of that nature,
but the energy in the room is lost, right.
Like the energy in the room is lost.
And so, to me, that is the
part that matters so much
in the equation of real life.
To me, I always say the
digital is a gateway drug.
Hey, Kim.
- [Kim] Hey.
Digital is the gateway drug
to the human interaction.
As a matter of fact,
it's funny, not Andrew,
who didn't know who the fuck I was,
but a lot of the people
here on the team, and Zak,
but a lot of people here on the team--
India, did you know who I was?
- [India] When I started here
or when I started your team?
(laughter)
That answered that question.
There was a gateway drug
happening before they got here
which created context, but then,
meeting in real life takes
it to a whole other level.
You could work for the company
and then you have a
whole different context
when you're on the team.
(laughter)
You know what I mean.
- [Voiceover] Frank asks,
"How did you meet Willie Morris,
"and what attracted you to Faithbox?
- Frank, you know, Willie,
Faithbox, I'm an early
early angel investor.
True angel investor in
both Birchbox and Barkbox
and believe in the box of
the month business model.
Especially when you lay
your media on top of it,
which those companies have done well.
I really wanted to be in that space
and really thought of like,
where's the biggest open space?
What's a big business to
be in in the box space?
And, you know, religion is a big business.
And so, I thought that was fascinating.
It was in the back of my mind.
It was brainstorming.
Phil Toronto, who is a
principal at Vayner/RSE
was aware of Willie through maybe
a girlfriend's girlfriend, friend.
He was leaving Amazon, coming to New York,
I take a lot of serendipitous meetings.
We sat down.
We hit it off.
I thought he had the right make up.
He had great hair.
And we made the move.
That's about it.
It wasn't super complicated.
I had an idea.
Got to know him a little bit.
There was some correlations on passion
around that subject matter.
It clicked.
And away we go.
And he's really kicking it in right now.
Faithbox is really looking on the up.
I'm really excited about
that company right now.
You know what, I'm gonna
throw a right hook.
Link it up, DRock.
- What's up Gary?
It's been a minute.
Listen, I wanna talk about being selfish.
How do you best make
decisions in your own interest
even though they might negatively
affect people around you.
That's family, business,
personal, friends, anything.
Let me know.
- You know how long I've known this kid?
- How long?
- I think there may be a video of him
actually being on Wine Library TV.
- Really?
- Like, eight, nine years ago.
Okay, play it again.
Jackson.
- [Voiceover] It's been a minute.
Listen, I wanna talk about being selfish.
How do you best make
decisions in your own interest
even though they might negatively
affect people around you.
That's family, business,
personal, friends, anything.
- Great question.
Great, great, great, great,
great question, Jackson.
There's an interesting
part of your question.
I truly truly don't think that
when I'm being selfish,
it's coming at the
detriment of somebody else.
And so that's how I handle it.
I think I'm always
selfish and never selfish.
Like, it's just, I'm living.
I'm living.
The way I justify it a lot of times is
I feel like when I'm in
my most selfish place
it's that I'm doing
something that optically
looks selfish for me in the short term
but is actually gonna positively affect
the people in the long term
and that I'm making a decision
and I think I'm right
in a five year window
versus a five month window and that
history will allow that person to feel
that it was palpable when they
rekindle their thoughts around it,
even though it might
sting or not feel as great
in the short term.
Crap, I really.
You know what.
Put in Jackson Fall.
You did the right one?
- I know how to use Google.
- It's really not that
hard to Google, is it?
Put in Jackson Fall Wine Library.
- [Voiceover] Jacob asks,
"If you could only make one post
"and then not post again for another year
"on any platform, what would your post be?
- That's a great question.
Who's this from?
- [India] Jacob.
- Jacob, two things went
through my mind fast.
Literally, I think fast.
So as India is asking the question,
I was like, the first one was gonna say,
"I love you."
And then the second one--
This is really--
This may be--
You know what, we need to
really think about this.
This might be the question
that most sums me up.
As you asked that question,
the first reaction was, "I love you."
The second reaction is, "What
call to action do I want?"
Which is like, "Buy my book."
or like, "Download my show."
or, "I promise I'll be back
"so sign up for my email newsletter."
It was literally, literally,
literally, literally,
the two most polar opposite thoughts
and that my friends, sums it up.
That's insane.
Because that was literally the two things.
But you know what makes me feel good,
now that I rewind this?
I thought of "I love you" first before.
(laughter)
So I still think I'm 51% good guy.
- [Steve] Put a call
to action to your website
and then you put "I love you"
for the rest of the year.
- Oh, you're a real
growth hacker, Steve Unwin
Question of the day.
What would be the one thing you would post
on a social network, on
all your social networks,
if it was the only thing
you could say for a year?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Cool.
- [DRock] Intro?
- [Voiceover] Yeah, we talked about.
- Oh, you know what, real quick,
I know you're gray and now
we're back to black and white.
Real quick, before we close this show out
if you're still with me.
Do we have all the information
for episode 100 down?
Like, we're feeling tight,
is everybody feeling good?
- [Everyone] Yeah.
- Yeah like, a couple of people painting.
The four year old kid is coming.
Ason, say it right, Ason, sorry, Ason.
Right, cause it's Jason, got it, Ason.
Everything else is good?
- Yeah, everything else is good.
- [Gary] Good and solid.
- And the Facebook invite
is up to date.
- Good.
See you Monday.
(upbeat music)